dans la série nos reportages insolites
se soit retirée sainte où ces cellules
farès ou font découvrir un canton de
l'ariège qui rit lutte là des moins
peuplée et des plus isolés de france
mais vous allez voir ce ne sont pas là
c'est seule particularité ici commence
le donner sens et ariège pas tout à fait
comme les autres puisqu'elle est coupé
du reste du département
huit à neuf mois par an sur le col de
pailhères les névés s'accroche tard dans
la saison
c'est cette neige qui coupe la route et
qui isole d'octobre à juin tout le
canton de quérigut tu au col de
pailhères
les restes de ces grandes kern de plus
de deux mètres deux roues nous montre
combien les paies brouillard pouvait
être aussi dangereux qu'un prévisible
pour éviter aux facteurs et aux
voyageurs de s'égarer ils furent
disposer la au xviiie siècle
aujourd'hui en ruine deux d'entre eux
seront peut être restauré le donezan
c'est exactement le canton de quérigut
un pays insolites par bien des aspects
tout d'abord c'est le canton le moins
peuplé de france 450 habitants ils sont
recensés il en reste moins de 300 en
hiver le donezan rattaché à l'ariège à
la révolution est en fait tourner vers
l'aude qui en limite la grande ville la
plus proche c'est perpignan catalogne en
208 le roi d'aragon et comte de
barcelone fait don de 7 petites
baronnies au comte de foix
c'est le début du rattachement du
donezan à l'ariège si on n'avait rien eu
le papier de préfecture quelque chose il
faut la foi et pour à la fois surtout il
faut faire un détour il faut passer par
qian ce qui fait 100 km et pour question
de ravitaillement que ce soit pour le
café que je vois pour la nourriture
pendant la vie dure à la pp en cours et
perpignan l'altitude moyenne du donezan
se situe vers 13 100 m c'est un pays de
montaigne depuis plus de mille ans on y
vit d'élevage et d'agriculture la guerre
de 14 et lecteurs de rurales et les
difficultés de l'agriculture de montagne
ont vidé peu à peu le canton aujourd'hui
cette commune du quérigut veulent avant
tout privilégier le tourisme la petite
station de ski de mijanès où les
nombreux gîtes les centres de vacances
attire une clientèle familiale tous les
ans plus nombreuses la pêche les
randonnées à pied ou à cheval
le canoë dans les lacs sont proposées
tout l'été mais le reste de l'année
la vie est dure pour une population à la
moyenne d'âge très élevé 180 en présence
ne veut pas d'eux des antennistes repas
de l'ue ne soient ferons pas de médecine
spécialisée donc chaque fois qu'il ya un
problème
en étant ici la liste d'invités
ça c'est mutuelle l'instituteur de
quérigut c'est lui qui sonne l'angélus
c'est aussi lui qui parle à la radio un
système de haut parleurs diffuser les
informations dans tout le village et
même la publicité
au confluent de trois qu'il va le donner
en possède une flore uniques avec de
nombreuses espèces endémiques
ce petit pays subit un climat océanique
venue du nord-ouest donc de l'ariège un
climat méditerranéen qui remonte la
vallée de l'aude et un climat
continental
portés par les vents d'espagne la vie y
est rude un hiver doux ça n'était et
reste encore à l'écart des hordes de
touristes